Займатися улюбленою справою – справжнє щастя
І нам під силу розрахувати його формулу
Ловіть покрокову інструкцію!
Крок перший. Отримайте достатньо інформації
Тільки у професійній освіті є сотні професій, кожна
з яких особлива та цікава
Але школярі часто знають лише про кілька десятків
Дізнатися більше допоможуть різноманітні тести,
ярмарки професій та дні кар’єри
Інформація про них є на сайтах закладів освіти,
Міністерства освіти і науки,
центрів зайнятості та обласних управлінь освіти
Крок другий. Визначте інтереси дитини
Дорослі часто мають нереалізовані мрії
Але діти не зобов'язані їх втілювати
Визначте інтереси своєї дитини, і працюйте з ними
Крок третій. Складіть перелік професій, серед яких обираєте
Обравши робітничу професію, якої навчають
у закладах професійної освіти,
можна швидко отримати знання і навички,
які будуть актуальні на ринку праці
Крок четвертий. Відвідайте заклад, який навчає обраній професії
Розпитайте особисто про умови навчання,
оцініть інфраструктуру
та поспілкуйтеся з майбутніми вчителями
Крок п'ятий. Вступайте до обраного закладу та отримайте професію мрії!